valéry giscard d'estaing dans le loiret
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
publiques dans la région
ce 24 juin 2010 est l'ancien chef de
l'état participe à l'inauguration du
château musée de gien il découvre alors
une exposition consacrée à la chasse
en fin connaisseur il apprécie j'ai
cherché beaucoup en france mais en
france c'est plutôt un sport mais j'ai
cherché tous les ans en afrique au moins
une fois et lâché vivre avec la nature
la chasse un domaine très appréciée de
l'ancien président en 1976 le voici à
chambord où il vient de participer à une
chasse présidentielle
l'occasion aussi pour lui d'échanger
avec des habitants
lettre ne calme pas été pris ce jour-là
merci d'avoir raconté
valéry giscard d'estaing est souvent
venu dans cette partie du loir et cher
à l'autre bout du département autant une
commune de 700 habitants
la famille y possède une propriété son
épouse anne aymone a grandi là bas
autant une commune où l'ancien président
s'est mariée et où il souhaite un jour
être inhumé autre ville autre temps fort
les fêtes johanniques d'orléans
en 1979 il assiste aux différentes
cérémonies
il était déjà venu deux ans plus tôt et
même en 1970 il était alors ministre de
l'économie et des finances de georges
pompidou flexion